hello everyone ah my name is young and
together with John will talk about
notebooks and graphics in the Wolfram
cloud today so most of you probably know
the notebook interface of desktop
Mathematica where you edit your
notebooks you do your computations you
interact with dynamic content and and
our mission is to bring that experience
to the web so the idea is that you have
that full blown notebook interface in a
web browser without installing any
plugin or installing any any local
software you get that so same sort of
experience right in your web browser and
that's not only interesting because it
allows you to edit stuff in the cloud in
your web browser but also because it
allows you to deploy things into the
cloud so that you can share your content
whether you created on desktop or in the
cloud with other people anywhere um and
what you see here is actually such a
cloud notebook so I'm in a web browser
it's just running on my local machine so
that we don't have any issues with with
network but it's it's using the same
kind of cloud notebook technology to
render this this notebook and in these
slides so let's dive into this and see
what we can do here in case you've not
seen it yet so this is this is the usual
notebook interface where you can type
stuff you press shift enter to evaluate
things you get back a result you can get
you can create different kinds of cells
like subsections and text cells of
course and and in the cloud during in
this case on my local machine there is a
regular mathematica colonel running so
you can do all sorts of things that you
can do with Mathematica like do math for
instance and if you integrate such a
thing get back an output it's not
looking completely perfect yet but I
think we're getting better and better
and so this is this is actually rendered
right in the browser using the
JavaScript fondant
it's not it's not a static image either
so if you go and resize the browser page
you will see that this this line reps
pretty nicely without fetching a new
image or anything so that's that's yup
all sorts of output you can get and of
course notebooks are also about dynamic
user interfaces so a very simple example
you can have a button in your notebook
that when you click it print something
into your notebook um just some very
basic examples and John will talk more
about graphics in notebooks okay so yeah
I'm the primary person who deals with
graphics in the cloud is a lot of work
but we support graphics pretty very very
well in the cloud so here I'm starting
with our 2d graphics and again is
important to note this is not a bitmap
or raster this is this case the
implementation here is SVG so we can
select it we can resize it it's a it's
pretty cool at least for me and it's a
lot of work goes into this and again
here is a different example I'm going to
show off the actual tooltip feature if I
can mouse over this kind of correctly so
it's kind of small you can't see that
but you mouse over the the point on the
on this graph plot and we have a little
mouse over and again that's natively
rendered in the browser okay and again
this one is also resizable so here again
is another example for that of what
we're supporting again it's it's
generalized at the box level so it's not
anything spectacular any graphics will
work similarly what about 3d well again
we've done a very good job to support
this this is interactive ok you have
rotation
you can zoom and you can pan ok this is
using WebGL and again a lot of work went
into into supporting this correctly at
the box level so it just works for other
types of things that type that as
graphics 3d so here's the case with
parametric plot 3d with a mesh option
again it's rotatable and here again just
kind of something showing off the the
lighting that is supported in this case
on the sphere and again because of how
it's implemented it just works with all
things that end up type setting is
graphics 3d in this case a chemical data
molecular plot of caffeine so needs to
download some some stuff to grab that
model and there we go and again
interactive
and I just have one more example here
okay and then I'll turn it back over to
young he's going to talk about some
dynamic mm-hmm so besides graphics I
think that's a another fundamental
building block of notebooks this dynamic
feature at the most fundamental level
what you have is some area on the screen
that says this is bound to some kernel
variables so we if you have dynamic of s
and later in some other evaluation
assign a value to s that part of the
screen will will update dynamically
that's been working for a while I think
what we added support for other recently
is also dynamic option values so here we
have some style the the font sizes
aesthetic value but the font color is
dynamically bound to a variable C now as
soon as your as a update value of C the
text color changes dynamically and with
these fundamental building blocks you
can you can build all sorts of dynamic
interfaces especially when you link
things together so i can i can create
another control that's also bound to
this variable C and as soon as I click
that color setter and choose a different
color you will see that the text color
changes changes immediately so yeah that
that's something that allows you to to
build interesting interfaces now what we
also changed rather recently is support
for continuous action so not too long
ago it you only you only got an update
from a slider when you clicked at a
certain point but what makes it more
interesting of course is if you can drag
the slider and get feedback immediately
and that's that's what we just
implemented now what you also see here
is this little ghost slider as we call
it and that's that's an indicator that
shows you've read the current Colonel
value is because there's always going to
be some latency between the client and
the server
and they have to communicate over the
internet so so in order to give some
feedback what's going on in the
background we show this little ghost
slider and that's basically reflecting
the number you also see on the on the
right another update we were just making
to the dynamic functionality is support
for pre-emptive evaluations that's
important when you have a notebook with
some long-running evaluations while
you're also interacting with dynamic
content so I mean this is some
artificially long delay but at the same
time while this shift entry valuation is
running I can still drag this slider and
get updates immediately it's basically
making a short interrupt to the colonel
and getting an update for the
photodynamic right away so that's some
some updates to the core dynamic
functionality something that's very
related to dynamic is dynamic module
it's maybe a bit hard to understand at
first what it does with the main two
points of dynamic module are that it
persists variables in your notebook so
if you have some dynamic very dynamic
module variable that's bound to control
you change the variable and then you
close your notebook and open it again it
will persist so it will have the same
value even after opening a notebook
again and the second point is that I
mean it's related of course is that
these variables are sort of owned by the
front end so then some computation
involves these dynamic module variables
in some cases it can it can skip going
to the colonel to do the computation
which can actually stay in the front end
and do the evaluation there and that's
particularly interesting in the cloud
where the trip to the colonel might take
even longer so so you might want to to
save some time by using a dynamic module
to demonstrate this I have fear simple
example where we have graphics with a
with an event handler and as you mouse
over it it increments a counter that you
see on the right
it's it's sort of okay but you can see
sometimes there's quite of a lag right
I'm constantly moving moving my mouse
it's not updating continuously now the
same thing we have here wrapped in a
dynamic module again we have some
variable but this time it's owned by the
front end so as I'm moving my mouse here
you can see it it's updating much much
faster and the reason again is that this
this increment operation here and also
the assignment are purely happening in
the JavaScript client right in your
browser without going back to the to the
colonel so we invested some some
development effort into implementing
certain colonel features in in the
JavaScript client as well of course I
found out everything but but simple
things that allow you to build certain
dynamic interfaces do work and one
interesting thing that we built with
this is assumable graphics I won't go
into the details but but it is basically
that again you have a dynamic module
that keeps track of two positions you
you click on some position and you then
you drag a rectangle and you let go of
your mouse and then it zooms into that
area of the graphics so yeah there's a
module and then in the graphics you have
this dynamic thing for the rectangle as
you as you drag and the plot range makes
use of a dynamic option value now if you
evaluate this and then they create some
plot with this zoomable wrapper we get
the plot as usual but now I can click
somewhere and drag the mouse around and
you see this this rectangle being drawn
and this is now making use of that
functionality I showed earlier this is
not going back to the colonel while I
drag the mouse around it's just staying
on the client side otherwise this would
never be as responsive and now as a let
go somewhere it seems into that that
region can repeat that
so you can swim closer and I also
included a reset button so that resets
it to the original plot range thank you
so I think that the really cool aspect
of this is that that we basically
provide the fundamental building blocks
for for you to build dynamic interfaces
using the Wolfram language um yet that's
a very interesting aspect at the same
time of course sometimes it's better to
build things right into the system to
have native implementations of certain
things in JavaScript and that's what
tone is briefly going to talk about okay
glad you like the zoo mobile plus there
it took quite a bit of work it's tricky
to get that to work correctly within
graphics the full dynamic capability of
the front-end still something we're
working on but as John said kind of
interactive so here you kind of built
your own interactive graphic and what
we're working on on the cloud side which
is great because it's a little bit
easier for us to try and demo new
features just from how it's built it's a
little harder to add those in the front
end but it's something we're working on
the desktop team and in the cloud for
kind of built-in interactive graphics so
I kind of have a pre generated example
here with a list plot and with a little
bit of setting of an option here in the
method we get a nice interactive drop
line okay much much simpler than a more
complicated code that you saw in the
previous slide and again another kind of
similar example a not very super
interesting but but something to kind of
shut off here is highlighting points so
I purposely made the magnification
pretty high here so you can see it again
it's kind of built-in interact
interactivity the next example here just
does both so we highlight the point and
we draw some drop lines and again just
to show you that this is kind of can be
built in capability here's an example we
don't specify any options and the
default behavior is to draw a drop line
and highlight the point okay so that's
that's something that
working on in the cloud side and also in
the in the desktop moving forward and
again as John said the the really cool
part of getting some of these things
these building blocks working in the
cloud is that you can kind of see it all
come together one very good example of
showing this off is manipulated so we've
had manipulate support in the cloud for
some time but initially it was a kind of
a custom implementation we didn't have
the dynamic module or dynamic or
continuous updating kind of supported
yet so it was more of a custom kind of
built into our JavaScript front end and
while it did work it wasn't very
generalized so we only had a very kind
of small portion of manipulate supported
but thanks to all of the kind of
building block level work we get we're
now supporting a box based manipulate
and it works much much nicer and more
generally so here again we're updating
one of the new boxes that we've
implemented is animator in the cloud so
there you go it's animating and again
this comes from the low-level constructs
that we built up you should be
applauding this is very cool to get
working in the cloud so so yeah you can
thank Ian for that up here in front did
a lot of work for us we worked very
closely with the front end group and
they helped us out a lot so again here's
just some other manipulate examples to
kind of show that this is just working
more at the box base level here we have
the plot within again very
straightforward a bit more complicated
example here's our 3d graphic inside
this and if you have used the cloud
earlier you would have known that before
this was only an image now it's the
proper graphics that's embedded in there
so you can if I can click correctly you
can rotate this with inside the
manipulate and zoom and pan etc so again
that that comes from supporting this at
the box level kind of from
from the low level up here's another
example just kind of showing off more of
the controls and think to notice here is
we have three different graphics
embedded within this manipulate this is
something that was not really possible
at our previous implementation it just
works because like I said we supported
the the box level functions and then
here's another kind of example that I
like which kind of shows off some of the
things we support in terms of like the
drop-down controls and such so
okay so again that comes from building
the building blocks and we get a lot of
things that just start to work in
manipulate that previously didn't so
speaking of those types of controls and
supporting other boxes one very commonly
used control is located or a locator
pain and this is something that i just
added support for in the last few months
by popular demand from somebody who i
won't mention so again the very
simplistic case but it gets more
interesting because it works with
dynamic so here we have three locators
and we're going to dynamically update
the position and it just works okay with
the low-level things that that yon
talked about would we properly support
dynamic module it makes it much much
easier to implement the locator pain
again i'll just give another few
examples this one is pretty neat we're
tying a slider to the locator so here we
go and just to show you it's not just
one way and then another one here sorry
missed this one again I have a polygon
defined by some locator points and we
drag them around and it gets updated so
not-it's not quite as snappy as the
desktop front end but again something
that we're looking to improve and my
last example again kind of similar but
just a different type of plot that we
just we get kind of for free because
everything is working together at the
box level so again another thing that
seems kind of simple which is sound uses
a lot of these kind of things we talked
about together in the presentation this
also now works natively in the web
hopefully you can hear this
probably not way in the back but if you
this now works in a web browser playing
your audio file so so again one of the
things we kind of kind of get from all
the comedy all the box level support
kind of coming in together I'll turn it
back over to yon to talk about something
a bit more interesting than rendering of
graphics deploy notebooks in the cloud
at all yeah so the questions of course
once you have your dynamic interfaces to
find somewhere how do you get them into
the cloud for other people to look at
them and the answer is simply cloud
deploy so when we take a manipulate like
this all you have to do is is apply the
function cloud deploy and what you get
back is a cloud object that has a URL
and when you go to that URL and this is
now opening just a different browser tab
it will give you that manipulate of
course that's that's interactive one
thing to keep in mind though is
permissions so the reason this just
worked is because I'm authenticated in
this in this browser session right now
so that's why I can see this object even
though it's private and I can I can look
at the permissions of the cloud object
and and that tells me that only the
owner of it can read write and execute
this this file if you were to open this
in a different browser where I'm not
authenticated so you would get to a sign
in page so this is not get a different
browser not authenticated it asks me to
authenticate if you want to share cloud
notebooks with with others you need to
to set different permissions and the
most straightforward one to share a
notebook with everyone is use public
permissions so if you cloud deploy with
permissions goes to public again you get
a notebook now and now this time I can
also open this
in a different browser we're not
authenticated and I should be able to
see the manipulate yeah and I can also
interact with it now again if you look
at the permissions it tells us this that
everyone has now read and interact
permissions there's a lot of granular
permission settings you can look it up
in the documentation for permissions I
should note that not all of them apply
to the deployed view of notebooks so
everything that's rated to editing
notebooks that's only allowed for people
that are using the the Wolfram
programming cloud as a product so in a
deployed view where the the viewer does
not have a subscription to the cloud
they won't be able to edit yet at least
it's something we still have to figure
out but reading a notebook I mean
looking at the notebook and interacting
with it that that always works fine so
much about cloud deploy one thing that
we also just noticed actually is that
due to this large piece of JavaScript
and all the resources that have to be
loaded for in order to render notebooks
it can take quite a while for quite a
while for notebooks to to render
especially for the first time and and we
wanted to address that somehow so so
what we came up with just now is this
week all HTML cash the idea is that when
you edit and also close a notebook we
generate a static piece of HTML that
represents the same piece of content but
it allows to it last browser to render
this piece of HTML immediately that that
really goes quite fast while in the
background it still loads the JavaScript
and all the other resources that are
necessary to render a notebook so if you
look at this um I'll just make this our
deployment that now has an artificial
delay in it so to manipulate the will
wait for three seconds and let's play
something the first time again we see
that you get you get this spinner and it
takes a while to come up
now when i visit the same notebook again
which in this case i can just do a
refreshing the page you'll see that it
always stays visible so now i'm already
on the new page sort of i still get that
spinner on the right that that's
indicating that something is the loading
but at least i was able to see the
content immediately so you can can see
something immediately it just takes a
little while to get interactive that's
that's the whole idea of of these HTML
caches we're still working on that quite
a bit so currently the way it works is
that the browser is sending some is
sending this HTML cash to the server
when you edit a notebook the waiver
changing is it is that will generate the
cash on the server side that gives us
more flexibility to account for
different devices different screen sizes
and so on so there will be more
improvements in that direction and then
our notebooks should really render quite
fast when anyone opens them another
thing that I wanted to want to briefly
talk about is how you can embed
notebooks in in websites so of course
notebooks are nice and ideally maybe the
whole internet would would be notebooks
but of course it's never going to be the
case you always have some pieces of HTML
some some pieces of JavaScript and you
might want these things to interact with
each other so what a brief you want a
demo here is if you have some some HTML
file like like this one here and you can
actually edit HTML files in the Wolfram
cloud as well you have this file it just
has a simple iframe in it that embeds
another notebook and then I added some
some JavaScript code that sort of talks
to that notebook I'll just going to show
this so we now open that HTML file and
these are basically native JavaScript
controls that any web developer could
write but but
here we have a regular notebook that
makes use of all the capabilities in the
Wolfram language now I can I can do
things like insert a new cell here that
evaluates something and since this
notebook down here uses a dynamic it
immediately updates to I can also use
this button to evaluate some expression
without inserting a cell or added this
little animate button that basically
continuously evaluates an expression to
increment the tea counter so now you'll
see this thing moving down there very
similar to what you could also choose
with animate a box but this time it's
demonstrating that that you can get this
sort of control in in JavaScript if you
care about that so we're still working
on this API it has quite a lot of
methods already but what would be really
interesting frost is if you have any
ideas what you want to do with this sort
of thing maybe we could talk about that
and take that into account as we design
and develop this API um and that already
brings us to the end pretty much um just
some outlook what's what's going on and
what we will be working on of course
we're constantly working on on improving
support for notebook and box rendering I
think we already came a pretty long way
but but there's always more work to do
and there will probably always be some
limitations that you just won't be able
to do in the cloud and we have some
efforts to document those limitations i
think that's something that we still
have to do so that you know what what
you can expect to work and what won't
work too soon um but but we working on
that and then more longer term things
are still a more advanced editor that
allows you to you know do two
dimensional
doing like Creed's as we saw before or
know things like super script and so on
that that's something that's a pretty
big challenge but I think eventually
we'll get there and another thing we
really want to get to is life
collaboration on cloud notebooks the
idea is that two or more people can work
on the same notebook at the same time
and you see changes immediately I think
we have a pretty strong framework to do
that now but it's still going to be
quite a bit of work to actually
implement it yeah that's basically what
we wanted to say or there's some related
talks coming up about cloud and also
using dynamic interfaces that might be
interesting are and I think we have some
time for questions now thank you